[Music]
[Music]
mm-hmm
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy
find practical advice that you can use
in your everyday life
hi i'm dan hayes and i'm joined by my
co-host dr greg sadler
today we're going to be talking about
the topic of
truth take two and so this is kind of a
holdover from our last session which was
also a holdover from the session before
that i hope we don't get into an
infinite loop here doing more and more
of these but the topic of truth there's
so much
to it that we weren't able to delve into
it to our satisfaction
we do have to do a bit of work i think
because
it sounds rather abstract right
but you know i think we can
provide you with a lot of examples and a
lot of insights that do relate
to our everyday life and so
we've got a lot of uh topics yet to
cover
in this but i thought we would do a
little bit of review for those who might
be listening for the first time or
who have forgotten what we talked about
last time
um so this as i said is a carryover of a
carryover we did a session a while back
on memory and truth
and dan and i had thought that we would
blaze our way through it
and get done with that quickly and
instead
we said oh we have to do a whole session
on the topic of truth
and then again we thought we would get
through all the topics that we wanted
and we
what did we get through about maybe half
of them yeah at best
uh our thoughts that we would get
through
them it was not a true thought at all it
was no you're right
it did not correspond to the reality of
our actual getting through these things
not at all and and actually we probably
should have known
better which would have you know tied in
in certain ways to the
the coherence theory of truth we could
have looked at you know previous
times in which we did stuff and said
this proposition that we're going to get
through all these topics
that can't be true given what we know
about
how we interact and the fact that we
almost
never get through all of our material
anyways
yeah i mean it is better to have too
much
than oh yeah enough right absolutely i
think we've done quite well with
the way that we kind of pick and choose
and uh
prune as we go that's true yeah
but not a lot of times do we actually go
oh man
we just need to keep on digging into it
and thus
if you were here third time's charm
maybe maybe not
well i and i think we talked before we
got started that we'll probably
also take up this topic of truth in
some more contemporary ways i'm talking
about
some people may remember the the the um
what was it not not a
it's an adjective truthiness right yeah
or no that would be a that would be a
noun right substantive
um that got coined during the bush era
is that a stephen colbert i believe i
think it was i think it was yeah
on that when he was back on the colbert
report that's
right yeah yeah or was was it did he
start talking about that on the daily
show
because that's i think that's where he
had his start right
all i know is it was that persona that
uh that
stephen colbert persona
yeah and and you know so there's a lot
of other things to talk about some
people say we live in a post-truth era
um certainly the last four years have
been
quite a time for that so i think we will
probably pick this up again
next time talking a little bit more
about truth in politics
and the marketplace of ideas but for
right now we want to
go further into talking about theories
of truth and perspectives on truth
we we actually started last time just to
review a little bit with some popular
sayings about truth and what they reveal
including the ever popular you can't
handle the truth
[Laughter]
and then we we discussed uh some
different modalities you could call them
logical empirical or experiential
moral we we did spend a good bit of time
talking about two traditionally
uh philosophically understood theories
the correspondence theory of truth and
the coherence
theory of truth and then we ended with a
little bit of a teaser about the
pragmatic theory of truth
and there was a quip that you had at the
end of that
i'm trying to remember it uh i think you
asked whether that was
practical to do or does that ring a bell
uh i don't know it's probably something
that is it practical to
even start getting into this without
actually getting fully into it or
maybe there's a lot of time to really
explore it yeah
yeah so we're going to make good on that
today
right right that's more semantics than
anything that's me just
messing with words because the actual
truth of the matter is when we actually
talk
about um pragmatism
there you know there is a definitely a
preconceived notion of this being
practical and what it actually is which
is
more a lot more especially if you
depending on
the uh pragmatic
uh philosopher that's actually the one
that's talking because yeah as with like
existentialism what is existentialism
kind of depends on
who you're talking which existentialist
you talk to exactly
yeah that's that's quite true and i
think that we could say that there's a
lot of
this is a bit of a digression there's a
lot of philosophical terms
that have come to take on
meanings that are sometimes
diametrically opposed to
what they originally started with i mean
dan and i are both members of
the milwaukee stoic fellowship are both
co-organizers and
there's this distinction that has come
to be made recently
between uppercase s stoicism the actual
philosophy and then lowercase
s you know stoicism the stiff upper lip
and you know the the idea of like say
repressing your emotions well that's the
lower case s that's not real stoicism
and you could say this about cynicism
utilitarianism it's
it's almost as if any journalism yeah
exactly yeah epicureans don't just stuff
their face
full and full of stuff um and get drunk
all the time
i i kind of think that with a lot of
these there's
a tendency once a term
has a popular what do we call it you
know
popular use popular acceptance it starts
to migrate
away from the original term
now could we talk about that in terms of
a loss or lack of truth is it is it
false for example to let's take
epicureans right so epicureans if you
actually read epictetus epicurus
sorry um he he doesn't think that you
should be indulging yourself
an awful light a awful lot in physical
pleasures you know he he thought that
having a little
nice cheese and bread was good
um you don't need to drink a lot you
don't need to have a lot of sex
um we nowadays associate epicureanism
most not so much with sex but i think
with with food and drink right and so
we have journals that are devoted to
that for foodies
is there a kind of lack or loss of truth
that's taken place
as the term has migrated
in its meaning what do you think for
epicureanism
yeah or in general we i mean we could
let me put you on the spot for both then
okay well first absolutely
you know uh epicureanism usually just
gets wrapped up
in it's like the base idea of like
hedonism but like hedonism even has a
worse rap than epicureanism true yeah i
think of um
oh the uh hedonism bot from futurama
which is a character who is just
like oh this is lovely as he gorgeous
himself and like
slathers himself with butter you know
it's just it is like this pure
just like uh to excessivism which is you
know
if you go to um i think one of the
my favorite like ideas of kind of
defining epicurean and hedonism
is uh to understand a
a pond that is very very
calm and there's no peaks nor valleys
within that lake and that would be kind
of like your
ideal um within epicureanism
um you know it feels good you're trying
to make sure that you're
you're not having the bads you know and
as well as
if you know you eat too much then it
also feels bad so also you're trying to
not get those things as well so a a
common smooth
pond is uh at least the understanding
that i have of it that i feel
is closer to this kind of idea of
hedonism
and then in general um yeah things
things
move all the time and i think as we'll
get into
in our next discussion especially when
we talk about like
uh truth and politics and that nature is
where we're
you know people because as we've been
talking about we have a whole bunch of
different kind of
base ideas of what truth is there's
these philosophical
uh groupings that uh define truth in
certain ways
under certain manners and
uh people are using the same word truth
but they
tend to um be speaking past each other
because they
the foundations by which they are
defining their truth
aren't always the same yeah and there's
there's often a problem with
you could call it not enough truth right
there's just enough truth to get you
into trouble you tell a story and this
part's true
and another part over here is true but
the stuff connecting them
up turns out to be if not completely
false
at least you know dubious and
you know when somebody fought somebody's
faulted for that they fall back and well
but but look over here this this
this one part is true you say yeah
that's that's that's fine
but the story you're telling is a false
narrative
i think that happens an awful lot in
not just in politics but in culture in
general um
you know when we think about who's who's
going to be
uh lauded or praised and who's going to
be condemned or criticized
to the main functions of you know our
moral language
and then you know how we organize things
how we prioritize things
truth can be an issue with those so that
should lead us to talking
we're going to do a little bit of review
for you we
talked a lot about these two theories
of truth that often get brought up in
philosophy textbooks or
encyclopedia entries or
people teaching intro classes a
correspondence theory of truth and a
coherence theory of truth do you want to
do a quick sum up of
of those before we talk a little bit
about why they
matter or what do you think oh yeah so
we've got um
correspondence kind of in a simple thing
that which comports
with reality so if i i take my teacup
here and i
i drop it
on the the
if i were to try to create a function
that would describe how this would
happen
and it actually does that when my
prediction now
uh predicts what actually happens in
testable in the
physical world then that would be
corresponding to the reality of
the world that we're you know
extensively living in
okay and so what's the coherence theory
then how does that
differ and so um coherence
requires a um
a hole that works together
in um i don't want to use coherent
um that's one of the tricky things
though
right we talk about truth and we're
often using
the words true and false to describe
them it's very difficult to get away
from these circular
types of um characterizations
right um i guess maybe a good way to say
it is
a um a map of reality that has
no um
oh we were just talking about it with of
time machines um
oh no paradox no paradoxes right yeah or
contradictions
contradictions or paradoxes yes yes i'd
say paradoxes
a contradiction set to a an extra level
yeah special kind of contradiction yeah
well i mean
i i guess i mean i think this this takes
us a little bit
out of our topic but there's different
kinds of paradoxes and some people
distinguish between like paradoxes
proper which is what what you're talking
about there
and then there's other things that it
just seems counterintuitive but it turns
out to be
turns out to be the case and these are
two different senses of the term
paradox um yeah i
i guess i think of like the whole idea
of was that um
is it zeno's arrow uh where moving
right where it's it's shot and it it's
um it has to go through half the
distance before it goes
through um and to go half the distance
it needs to go half of the half of the
distance
and then half of that distance and it
was you know and how could you have
never
actually have the the arrow hitting the
target right yeah and it
like well there's no motion then because
yeah how
if it goes add infant item to the end
then you never
get there and i think we solved that
finally with calculus
no aristotle pointed out the problem
with that already back then he said
listen you're abstracting away from time
it takes you half as long to get to the
next point as
you know the previous thing and pretty
soon you're there
because you get an infinite intensively
small amount of time
to move an infinitesimally small amount
of race
which you cross you know yeah and then
suddenly boom the arrow is
in the target or what were the other
ones there was achilles in the tortoise
achilles does catch the tortoise
there was that weird one about the two
chariots i think it is that are like
approaching each other
in the arena um yeah eris
actually it's because of aristotle i
think if i remember right
that we actually do have the xenos
paradoxes
that we currently possess because zeno
is supposed to have written more
but nobody nobody managed to keep track
of them
if if i remember the story right um
so i just like love that idea of like
okay this guy he's like
oh he's thinking about some things he's
like well this seems really weird
he starts writing them and keeps like
well i'm gonna keep on writing and
writing writing and starts like passing
out can you understand this can you
understand this
he's in the marketplace like hey this is
really weird
well you know uh zeno's reason for
for coming up with the paradoxes is he
was a student of parmenides
and permanentes claimed that there was
no motion
and which is you know that's pretty
counter-intuitive
and permanently has claimed a whole
bunch of other things
too where we're like yeah i don't know
about that you know does that correspond
with reality
that's where it gets really interesting
i think strictly speaking
you couldn't have you couldn't use the
correspondence
theory for permanentes because he's
talking about these things like
being or you know motion or or
justice and um and he's he's basically
saying
everything is is one thing
and that thought and being are the same
now how would you
possibly compare
a statement like that except to say well
this is just this
can't be the way things are it doesn't
correspond to anything how do you take a
statement like that
and map it against the reality that we
were looking at because we could be
wrong maybe maybe you and i are the same
thing and all of our listeners are the
same thing
and you know we're we're just stuck in
an illusion here which is parmenides
basic take
um right i think he'd have to have a
correspondence approach
rather and say does this does this make
sense together
you know you mean a coherence
oh right sorry yeah coherence theory
yeah
yes oh yeah and i think he was created
trying to create
a coherent set of axioms
on yeah if not axioms at least
statements
um it's it's i mean this is very
paradoxical as well
because um parmenides wrote this in the
form of a poem
which has like characters in it he meets
a goddess and the goddess reveals this
to him
and you know when you think about that
you're like well wait a second
if what the goddess revealed to you is
actually true
then there wasn't any goddess and there
wasn't any you
it we're all just like one single thing
thinking this
this basic thought so why did you put it
in the form of a poem
is it for all of us dummies that can't
you know get straight philosophy or
were you just showing off or what's the
deal permanentes you know
yeah well going on with with this so
you know both coherence and uh
correspondence there you know reputable
theories of truth a lot of people who've
espoused these
over the history of ideas going all the
way back to
plato and aristotle and they do capture
something that's really essential to
our everyday lives as dan was just
pointing out
you know making claims about cups and
what happens if they fall or if there's
tea in the cup
or you know uh rocket fuel or pick
whatever else you want
those are things that we can you know we
know how to solve those
if i say i have got a million dollars in
the bank you can go and check my bank
accounts and as it turns out no that's
that's not the case at all
um with co with the correspond coherence
theory of truth
we you know we map things on to each
other that's often how we figure out
cases where we can't directly look at
stuff we say well does this make sense
with the stuff that we know
over here and we do a lot of our
living in that way neither one of them
is completely adequate they don't
provide us with
everything that we need to grasp truth
but they're both
useful in a lot of scenarios and
situations
and considered as theories they both
give us answers to you know we talk
about philosophy as being about the big
questions right so
a big question what is truth what does
it mean for something to actually
be true or false what makes it true
or false and i think that you know we
don't want to throw these out for the
next shiny
thing right these are you know
tested and true again we're using that
kind of a facetious way
um theories that that help us express
what we mean by truth
i mean i think that let me bounce an
idea off of you
as human beings no matter where we grow
up no matter
what kind of situation we're in whether
we've ever heard of
philosophical theories of truth or not
we inevitably use both the
correspondence theory and the coherence
theory
to make sense out of our lives what do
you think
yes in and we do it in different ways i
guess you know
okay depends depends on the person as
well uh
yeah uh a lot of times like we're going
to be talking about
things that don't actually exist
but we want to try to make some truths
about them
um then then there has to be some
uh like there's something there's
nothing you can like test it against
and so like yo what is justice
as an individual idea can there be a
truth that actually
corresponds to something that you know
only really kind of collectively lives
within our brains um
and then and then there are certain
things that are like partially real but
then we do have some ways of testing
them but they're also kind of like
shaking their foundation so i think like
economics here
and so we've got all this money and
interaction and it's it's based on the
the general way that people interact
with each other um
based on certain axioms but all
these axioms don't always hold and
because
we are these really fickle creatures um
even though the best models
usually have you know you can't like
predict the stock market at least so far
we can't predict the stock market
maybe if we had um
uh oh what's that demon
i was just thinking about him um
they'll come to him later um if we had a
uh
a ability to know every single movement
of every single atom in the universe and
like you knew everything was going to
happen
um yeah maybe you could
um potentially predict that but it
there's just
so many factors that are outside of our
ability to
actually ascertain that it is
at least a fool's errand to say that
there's going to be absolutes you might
be have
like you know within you know 20 point
range
you can make some predictions but they
go particularly bad over
especially long periods of time yeah
i mean it's interesting when you're
talking about something like the stock
market
right it's supposed to be representing
value of
you know broadly speaking these
organizational units that we call
companies and there is a predictive
factor to it like you're pointing out
like you know
back in the day you bought stock not
just to swap it and sell it really
quickly but because it was going to pay
dividends and you're kind of you're kind
of guessing or betting
on certain things and you might know
certain factors like you know
you're buying up i don't know
well right so right now interestingly we
were talking about this beforehand
donald trump has um started some
lawsuits some class action lawsuits
against the big
tech companies who who are the top
market cap
companies well at least you know google
and facebook are twitter isn't yet
twitter's kind of in the second tier and
those are the three companies
and you know we can look at that and we
can say oh man should i buy
facebook or should i sell facebook based
on that and you know
if i had any money to spend on that i
would probably buy it at this point in
time because
i expect that the lawsuits are going to
be tossed and that might actually have a
positive effect
but you know we're doing this kind of
prediction and we and we do so
bringing together all these factors that
we are dealing with as matters of
real abstraction i mean we we can't
you know there's no way in which we can
like look into
apple as a company or amazon as a
company and see all the different things
that are going on we have to engage in
these these abstractions
that get get provided to us in myriad
ways
and then we see whether they cohere
whether they make
sense and very often the decisions that
we're making
whether it be that or whether you know
whether we're taking a job
somewhere whether we go and date
somebody or marry them or
you know whether we have kids or don't
have kids these are not based on like
knowing the reality of everything and
and uh having a you know pure
correspondence between
the things outside and the factors yet
to come
and our minds or our language we have to
rely
quite often on something like a
coherence theory of truth and we pick
and choose things and we're like well
this thing that we used to believe
that's out but this thing over here
we're gonna
we're gonna double down on that one and
we're going to bring this new one in
it's sort of like having a circle of
friends and
you could only have i don't know 10 of
them in the elevator or something and
you're like that
this guy's coming in somebody else get
out
uh bringing out the stock market is is
really interesting for
you know as you said it's obsessively
about like
the the value of the stock should
correspond or like it it should have
some relation
to the actual value that the company is
providing
yeah but then but then you also see
bubbles that happen right big bubbles
like the 90s we had the big bubble and
also like
right now there's um like the meme
stocks we've got our game stock we've
got our
amc and and so that's like
who knows if if what the heck gamestop
is actually valued at
but there's a whole bunch of people that
are buying it but partially because they
believe that it's going to hurt someone
else these big
um uh certain uh traitors
on institutional straighters on wall
street
um because they've got shorts on them
and so like well
if they can't pay the shorts they have
to pay us you know
that has totally thrown out the you know
is gamestop actually worth it
no it that doesn't hold anymore
whatsoever
and it's getting a lot of people angry
because
they are using the stock market in a way
that does not
agree with that idea of what the truth
of stock is supposed to represent
you know there's another wrinkle as well
that we can add to this so
you know whenever anything happens um
that's considered a big deal somebody
will produce a tv show or movie about it
and so you know like terrible crimes
take place right we have a whole
you know uh let's talk about murders and
and rapes and
financial misdeeds over here you know
they get turned into dateline
episodes or whatever and we also have
all these other things that have to do
with um
you know like the you mentioned
financial crisis so there was one
about the 2008 housing crisis that led
to the the meltdown that we're still
recovering from today
the biggest should have been a couple
different like that yeah that's right
yeah now with gamestop
the the cycle has gotten so um
fast and close that there were with even
though
even before all of this stuff was being
sorted out there were already people
putting together
proposals and scripts about what would
be
you know the next movie about this now
here's so here's two questions to think
about
and i don't actually have any good
answer about these so when when we see
these movies right whether they're
about financial things or like think
about erin brockovich
you know just the sheer fact that
hollywood has
put money into it and it's been fit into
this nice 90-minute sequence
you know that there's some some things
that are going to be false right and
when you go online you find out that
yeah most of these
um based on a true story movies are like
way divergent from
the truth of what was actually going on
and maybe
that's partly due to the fact that they
think we're dummies and you know we like
you know happy sappy stuff or
maybe it's just the format of things or
maybe there's too few people working on
this this sort of thing
it must conform to a three-act structure
yeah yeah well i think that
they have that sort of thing in mind
right yeah now there's some things that
are easier to
portray in a way that would like
correspond to something
like you know people getting sick from
say fracking
water you know um but trying to
make a movie about buying and selling
stocks
you know i mean you could do with things
like boiler room that
that had like a vin diesel in it and a
few other people
where you show people selling crappy
stocks to people
and basically you know like ruining
these people's lives by
getting them to invest their their life
savings in it but that's
that's a certain picture does it
correspond to
a reality i don't know i mean i don't
know people in boiler rooms
um but but with this sort of thing like
the games the game
uh stop thing how do you make a movie
about that that actually corresponds to
anything
and people would watch right and there's
so many actors that you can't like say
like
i guess there's there's one guy oh what
is his name
um big effing
value i think his name is um
uh really yeah that says this
is a reddit tagline yeah
and so he was the the guy that like put
out um
basically that everything was shorted
way over it should be
and so here here's a really interesting
segue okay
um game stock as pragmatic truth
they don't care about what the spock
market
is supposed to be they are only
caring about that the fact that they saw
that someone was
very leveraged on this and if the price
went up
they had to pay out and so they knew
the rules of the system and
that certain people were over leveraged
and if they can convince enough other
people to also buy into this
they would all basically make out so it
wasn't they totally threw out the basic
idea of like
you know uh stock value being
a representation of the value of the
company like no
we we can just we we know the rules
these
contracts come up and then they have to
pay them out
and so it works uh we we we got our
money and we also took it from like the
big
wall street guys who you know uh if you
hadn't noticed
are not very well liked around the
country
yeah and so there's sort of a double
motive there right let's make some money
but let's also
stick it to this group of people and and
either one of them could be a sufficient
motive i
i suppose right like even if they didn't
make that much money
so long as the the hated wall street
guys
um got theirs you know got their
comeuppance
that might be sufficient to to do that
well let's talk about the pragmatic
theory of truth that's something we
brought up last time
and got to mention a little bit
um it's it's a bit more complex than it
is often portrayed as um
so you know there's sound bite
characterizations of of it and some of
these sound bites actually a lot of
these sound bites
are attributable to one of the main
pragmatist philosophers
william james also a psychologist um
and and you know brother of henry james
the novelist
um so does that just mean being
practical
greg well so that goes back to what we
were talking about before right there's
the
popular or um what else should we call
it the
common usage yeah the ordinary usage
right
if i say let's be pragmatic you know how
much are
how much can we actually talk about on
this show
you know maybe then it is just a
substitute for being
practical um or you know uh
what else what would be some other
practical things you and i have decided
about
about the show at different points uh
you know should we have an intro and
outro yeah well there you go
people people like to hear that kind of
stuff so
um maybe we should do that it's a
practical thing to do
and you could say well that that makes
it true in the sense that you can say
you ought to have an intro and outro it
becomes a true statement because
yeah it works right yeah or or the fact
that we actually have
like notes that's that's very important
i don't know that you and i could just
sit here and riff back and forth like
some people do on on podcasts
so it's practical for us for the way
that we do this particular podcast
that's yeah yeah so that's a good
example
um and going back to these sound bites
there's a lot of them out there you know
truth is what works that that's a
kind of famous one um truth is what is
useful
actually that that's got an uh longer
tale going back into the history of
of ideas i think the utilitarians can
sometimes
be you know talked about in that respect
james had this thing the cash value of
ideas
and that was a slogan that not only
represented pragmatism in a certain way
but also
made everybody overseas who didn't like
americans because i thought americans
were much too
money oriented and didn't have any
culture they were like yeah see those
americans
pragmatism is their philosophy they're
all about the cash value of ideas
no respect for history no respect for
culture no
no respect for anything else um these
are you know these actually do have
their origin
within works of pragmatist philosophers
but they lose something in being pulled
out of that that context
you might say they lose some of their
some of their truth
right um some of the the coherence
that's there
we actually picked out a couple
different um definitions
from online dictionaries and
encyclopedias that we thought we would
kick around so there's one was
an approach that assesses the truth or
meaning of theories or beliefs in terms
of
the success of their practical
application
that's not bad right um
what do you think
can this can this work for a definition
of
what it means to be true
it is definitely a definition uh i think
you could
there's definitely things that are left
out like
what is determined to success here yeah
well that's a big one
yeah it is um and
and what is i guess the practical
application of them
uh i feel like they're that is a little
bit
less defined at least in my immediate
looking at it
yeah i mean you could also have cases
where you make a decision or you commit
in
a certain way to a belief
and you do have good grounds for holding
that belief
but it doesn't lead to success
right or it doesn't lead to the success
that you you want it to
to display um even even putting aside
the question
what is success um right let's say you
actually do have a good
solid understanding of it does that
actually mean that the belief itself
isn't true i mean you might say well you
back up and you do an after action
assessment or whatever it is that you're
going to you're going to look at you
figure out
okay where did i go wrong and maybe
there are some false beliefs lurking in
the background
but that doesn't mean necessarily that
the belief that you're
operating on by itself is false
yeah it kind of reminds me of this um
misattribution thing of uh
you know when in during the summer
uh ice cream sales go up as well as the
on
shark attacks go up doesn't mean that
they are actually directly related
they're both related to the fact that
they happen during summer
um and so you could believe something
um but it and you think doing it
or or doing something at a certain time
um gets you that
the outcome that you want and it might
actually get the outcome you want
but it wouldn't actually be the thing
that is actually causing that thing even
though
you know this is kind of like um
oh oh like
doing some like i don't know rain dance
or some other
and and you do it like you assuming
because you go through a ceremony that
you've actually influenced the
cosmos in some way right um
and and maybe you just know that you've
always
done it when the days get so long and
that happens to be just before spring
when it starts to rain a lot
and so you know who knows you know
there's a number of different things of
hey these things tend to work out in the
way that they were working out but why
are they actually working out
yeah we don't understand the causality
behind them and we miss a tribute
what's causing what right well let's
look at the next one then so wikipedia
has
a philosophical tradition that considers
words and thought as tools and
instruments for prediction problem
solving and action
and rejects the idea that the function
of thought is to describe represent or
mirror reality i would say that's
actually
not bad if we have in mind a later
pragmatist like richard rorty who has
this book the mirror of nature in which
he says
you know people think that truth is all
about
um you know getting things right a
correspondence theory of
of truth and that's just not what's
really going on and he uses
um he draws on three different
traditions he draws on
john dewey the pragmatist or
instrumentalist philosophy draws on
martin heidegger
and he draws on uh ludwig wittgenstein
and he says look they're all
they're all basically saying the same
kind of thing you know we can never
have a mirror of nature we can never
really get the world
as it is instead what we what we have
are like projects
that we we try to do and and being true
is you know like when when we're able to
uh bring them off or when they
correspond to
our needs so you know prediction problem
solving and action
oh okay i think that
that's i mean it doesn't describe all of
pragmatism
but the the idea that words and
thought are tools and instruments that
sounds very much like john dewey
you know
yeah is there something about this one
that you don't like because i can see
i guess i i i i do
uh tend to go a little bit closer
towards
uh the correspondence than any of these
okay but um
there are definitely lots uh like you
can get a long way
with this and especially if you don't
happen to have all the tools at your
disposal to get to a perfect
representation of reality
um then this is definitely a good way to
go about that as well as it
it as you're just saying like this whole
idea of mirroring reality
on whenever we were making a
representation
of reality we'll never be able to
perfectly represent it
this is the and and even if we did how
would we know
right we'd have to have the reality in
front of us
and all of its complexity and then our
representation which presumably is also
part of that reality
and then we'd map them on to each other
um
yeah how would we do that and then and
that's the whole idea of the
uh the map is not the terrain whenever
you're making a map
there's always going to be some loss of
information now
we're talking about abstractions and so
now our abstractions are
like atomic units when we're actually
talking about
thought here or a truth and
the if you're abstracting and making
arguments from abstractions there's
always going to be
a loss it's going to be a lossy uh
truth but it might work and if that's
more useful then well that's probably
use
like that is a an end that i could see
as valuable i'll give you an example of
what you're talking
about that actually happens in the world
of ideas and in
teaching and learning so you know when
we have textbooks
or when we have kind of second-rate
histories of ideas or stuff like that
they put everything into nice neat boxes
right so you know in in the uh early
modern period we had the continental
rationalists and the
british empiricists and empiricists all
believe xyz
and rationalists believe to the contrary
abc
and so when you when you you know have
that sort of map
essentially a map of two different
things
you think that you can generalize from
it so then you you run into somebody who
you
you haven't read before like uh nicholas
malbrush who very few people
here in the united states read and he's
he's a rationalist but
he's not a rationalist in the same way
that like descartes although he is a
cartesian
or spinoza or leibniz
or our know where uh instead he's got
his own weird thing going on that you
really just gotta read and find out
about you know
and and you could do it through
secondary text you could like read
uh somebody else telling you about what
maul brunch has to say or blaise pascal
or even renee descartes or you could
read the actual texts
and when you're reading the actual text
you're getting to see what the author
him or herself really thinks about
things
not what somebody else says that they
think about things which is much
easier to to wrap your head around that
they did some work for you right but
they could be
they could be wrong and you never really
know
until you've read the original thinker
whether this first
this person over here telling you all
about them is on point or
full of it or somewhere in between right
and and i see a lot of people who they
they do and
they think they have an accurate map and
they've never actually checked it
against anything
so they know all about rene descartes
and you know he
he was uh this or he was that or he was
this or thomas hobbs or pick whoever
else
you like i mean people do this today too
they they have their categories
of people great example of this right
now is critical race theory right it's
this word that's getting bounced around
and you can say oh well that's that's
critical race theory and then you know
it's it's it's bad and you should ban it
or don't allow people to teach about it
or
whatever which is what's happening on
the side of
the the right and they're engaging in
these
really super sweeping generalizations of
things that include
you know it's like a giant box that
includes basically anything that
mentions
race at this point right and can you
successfully
generalize about that in a way that
would allow you to
you know attain success in
reaching you know intellectual truth or
a representation of how things
actually happened or even you know let's
say you've got other things in mind like
you know a lot of these laws
will be like well we want to have you
know we don't want people to be all
riled up we want there to be
harmony or concord or something like
that
are you really going to get that by
using these
these overly broad
categories or boxes no you're you're not
going to
and um so i see what's happening
i guess are they caring that it is
overly broad
this uh or their
their ends that they're trying to
achieve that's a good question because
there are some people who are involved
in in that i get to see this on twitter
quite a bit
who have come out and said we're just
doing propaganda essentially
against against what we're going to call
critical race theory we're succeeding
because we have managed to get people to
buy into the idea that there is such a
thing
as critical race theory as
like a category of thinking living and
stuff like that that is when things
well exactly yeah yeah because it stands
in the way of whatever
whatever it is that you want and
interestingly they will often make
claims that they know
are false about the falsity of
what is being put forward as theory not
to say that this only happens on the
right there are people on the left who
do that as a
argumentative strategy as well are they
are they really
so let's think about this are they
really being pragmatic they are in sort
of a debased sense
they have some they have some things
that they're after like
you know gaining political and cultural
power
is that going to be a long-term strategy
for success
or are they are they doing so much
damage to
the very arena that they would like to
dominate
that they're you know usually we talk
about scorched earth as you retreat and
you leave the earth scorch maybe they're
actually
wrecking things in the very area that
they want to take over
which is bad for all the rest of us who
are part of that war you know
right yeah and that's the whole idea
that i had problem with the the first
definition here what what ours
determines
success yeah yeah uh
so maybe let's go this scp pragmatism is
a philosophical tradition
that broadly understands knowing the
world
as inseparable from agency within it
that's a nice one isn't it it is
i like like we the only reason that we
have
truth is because we are agents with
minds
that can discern truth um
you know instead of like i guess the
argument is made that like
we developed as humans
not to know truth but to know
what gets our gene past genes passed
down
better and so you know our we will
yeah this john winnie sort of broadly
darwinian
right yeah you know like the whole i
guess you see a
a stick on the path and you jump back
because your brain thinks that it could
be a snake
and it's better to jump back and it not
be a stake then to not
jump back and it is um i'm reminded of
of
all the silly things with uh cats and
cucumbers
oh yeah if you haven't
go look that up on youtube it is very
entertaining
um but is it their enter they're
a distress uh a good if it is uh good
for our entertainment
what is the goal there right i'm just
thinking about like cats wandering
around and
seeing anything that's snake-like and
then recoiling
from it um it's kind of
you know in a way it's maladaptive isn't
it
yes in the instant but it is probably
rather adaptive
for the the long-term success of that
that individual or that species
yeah yeah
um so would you talk about some of these
uh classical figures
yeah so when we talk about american
pragmatism
as a movement we usually think there's
like a you know
like a trinity of them you could say
charles sanders purse
who was not particularly successful
in his life and actually had the term
pragmatism in his view stolen
by william james who used it to mean
something a bit different so
purse famously renamed his doctrine
pragmaticism saying that it's too ugly
of a word for anyone else to steal
and then we have john dewey who i think
a lot of people know
less from philosophy and more from his
massive effect on american education you
know or
you know um other things and he's often
viewed
by by people on the right because he was
for progressive education as being you
know
particularly problematic um
so those are the three big names but
there's a whole bunch of other people as
well that that gets sort of
mixed into it and pragmatism
interestingly enough wait
is it james i did yeah okay
uh james uh remember stole the word from
purse oh yes
um but there were people in italy and in
france and in other places who were
embracing pragmatism and james was like
a big go-getter he
wandered around you know meeting these
people
the person who i actually wrote my
dissertation on maurice blondel was a
french
19th and 20th century thinker and
he was willing to let
people call what his philosophy of
action there he was willing to let them
call it um
pragmatism until he found out what james
meant by it and then he was like nope
don't
don't call me that because because what
i'm doing is something kind of different
but there were a lot of these ideas kind
of floating around
in the air sometimes in the in the
present the people who are continuing
the pragmatist tradition will combine it
with
other traditions as well i mentioned
richard rorty
there's there's quite a few others in
the present it's part of the classical
american
tradition of philosophy and there's a
bit of diversity in what they
thought truth was and i know a bit more
about purse and james in part because
i had so much dewey kind of shoved down
my throat when i was a graduate student
at southern illinois university where
they have the dewey center where i did
actually work for a semester and
all these dewey ends who you know think
that he's the best thing
since sliced bread that i had
i'll admit that i'm not as up on dewey
since i'm almost 20 years out of
graduate school i haven't i don't read
dewey very much
but you know when it comes to person
james we see we see some competing ideas
and i think that that understanding them
can be
helpful for us purse seemed to think
at least at one point that truth is what
we
arrive at at a sort of consensus
way down the line so it's like a in a
way it's something we project out in
front of us
which means that maybe we won't ever
have
truth with a capital t about some things
you know maybe maybe not though i mean i
was going to say political matters but
i think we've managed to have some
progress that's been relatively lasting
where we're
we've at least figured out some things
um although i don't know we could always
backslide
yeah and it might be that we will come
to knew better truths and so like
our current political truths are right
are not
like the ends the the final ends
yeah and you know this is not what pers
himself has said
but if you think about the importance of
arriving at consensus
we're in a time where things are very
fragmented right and
we have this incredible political and
cultural polarization
um people don't want to like you know
spend time with they
talk to people from from what they view
as the other bad side
um we also have a pretty bad political
gridlock we're
unable to get important things actually
handled you know some people are like
yeah we should have a con you know we
should have a constitutional amendment
there's no way we could ever pull that
off in this
kind of environment it's just not going
to happen
and on the really big things like
environmental policy
or um having you know a good
health care system it seems like we're
we're kind of at impasses
and so if we can't arrive at consensuses
maybe
our there's you know there's nothing
that says that our society
has to continue to be on top of things
as a matter of fact we seem to be
in many respects quite quite in decline
for for decades
maybe if we look at things from a
pragmatic perspective our incredible
factionalization is actually a sign of
us being a bunch of losers it's the
opposite of success
i don't know that that's that's
something to think about
james talks about pragmatism as thinking
about differences that make a difference
he says that all true processes must
lead to the
to the face of directly verifying
sensible experiences somewhere so
you know there's there's the sense of
pragmatism being a theory of meaning and
and being a theory of truth you can say
well what do you actually mean by a term
and and we can say well what what
difference does does it make to believe
one thing or another
but there's also the sense in which if
you can't say
what would actually count as getting
things right or
success or making some sort of
difference you're really just
talking about vacuous stuff and you
probably don't realize that you're doing
so
um for something to be true there has to
be a kind of robustness about
affecting the world or or it could be
the world inside it could be about how
you feel about things
right there has to be some
experiential like thing to map that
yes yes yes and and the experience could
be a lot of different things
you know it could be um something very
straightforward like what happens in a
spreadsheet that we do in excel
in terms of money that we're making or
it could be um
how it corresponds to what
you know james calls our needs and
desires or our volitional
and passional nature and so this is
probably a place where we should
you know whatever worries we have about
this pragmatist theory of truth
we should put him on the table because
we're getting close to the end of the
the hour um do you have any
questions worries about this or i guess
the the first one is
how do we define you know it was one of
the things
from the what is the success from or
early on
like yes we can say like oh well you
know
i'm uh i've trusted this is what works
but what works right yeah yeah yeah
it's working um i don't want any
immigrants in my town
well i guess you know you could there
are a number of ways you could do these
things a lot of them could
be rather morally fraught right
probably the vast majority of them are
um
but uh if if your goal here was to
as i said to get all the immigrants out
of your town then
you know it might be pragmatic like
that's the pragmatic truth of like how
to get
people out of your town this is where i
think
we could talk about um like you know
sort of like a
kernel and then like a bigger thing that
surrounds it you know
success with a lowercase s might not
correspond to success that takes into
account
other things that matter to us like not
being dirt bags not being
people motivated by hate right maybe
that's that so successes could conflict
with each other
right and i think that's that's a real
issue
um i think we have to ramp up now so
yeah lead us out
yeah so we leave you today with the
words of
aristotle though we love
both the truth and our friends
piety requires us to honor the truth
first
[Music]
you